Let's talk about today
about something very important
that we need to clarify about it,
Distribution system or
kitten distribution system.
As you may know,
grandpa always prepares you for a cat in life,
that's why it's called the cat distribution system.
Cats bring you joy in life
and make you a better person.
So if you see a cat in the street.
to come up to you and say,
meow, meow, meow,
meow,
if you see,
you are walking and you see a cat in the snow
or just a cat approaches you and dies meow,
is that yellow
is preparing you for a cat.
Brings you a cat in life
so that you can be a better person.
That is why it is called a kitten distribution system.
There are people who have registered 5 kittens,
32 kittens.
I have two kittens.
So
accept the kitten distribution system and be happy.
That's a sign of paradise.
Have your cat